[Music]
we have a little bit of history here
we'll start with Andy you were hot Andy
on a movie I did years ago you you
worked on scary movie - I remember how
exciting it was finding out that we were
gonna be working with Marlon Brando who
was originally gonna play Max von Sydow
his role as Linda Blair you're the girl
on the bed who's possessed by the devil
yes and Andy plays the younger priests
priests and Marlon Brando was supposed
to play the yeah I mean he was also sick
at the time yeah and uh I was so excited
to work with him he had like that you
let your peace yeah yeah liver the lines
he had an assistant reading his lines
from another room so he didn't know his
lines he would just be listening to them
so we work yeah we'd be doing so I work
yeah he would say he would just be like
you know may the Lord bless I can't hear
you may the Lord bless I can't hear you
meanwhile he was saying to me I can't
hear you bet I was in the prosthetics
and like maybe twenty playing thirteen
with good genetics and uh and he just
like what in between takes hold on to my
boob while you waiting to receive the
information and I will be waiting you
know you're a great O'Hara's hey we sort
of like the power of Christ compels you
whatever and the power of Christ compels
you
what is it the power of Christ compels
you know and the whole time and I just
remember looking to you as a touchstone
of like sanity yeah I just looked away
tomorrow and Brando Brando it was like
the highlight of my professional career
I felt up by Brando